when people ask how I'm able to get
these videos done every single day my
calendar and erech SIA is the answer
hard work and patience are really what's
required to find success in any field in
life if you consider yourself a driven
person a passionate person's only two
things you should be doing need
motivation what's that belief nation
it's Evan this channel is designed to be
a part of your daily success routine and
help you believe in your Michael Jordan
level talent so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who went from
dropping out of high school and living
in a trailer park with his son as a
teenager to start in his moviemaking
career and becoming one of the biggest
YouTube creators of all time he's Casey
nice tat and here's my take on his top
ten rules a success vol 4 also if you
want to know what Casey and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a free morning video on
how to build your confidence the link is
in the description below skill is
probably communication which I mean
you're building on what Garrett said I
think communication is - a two-way
street
okay let's tick it off with rule number
one be a maker I will now read a
monologue I didn't write this monologue
but it's pretty spot-on
the person who emailed me this morning
with a perfectly nice request I'm sorry
to say the answer is no you didn't do
anything wrong you were perfectly
respectful within your rights to ask
about arranging a time for a meeting see
but the problem isn't you there's
something wrong with me
I have a form of anorexia don't be
alarmed it's not serious although I take
it quite seriously in fact in fact I
think it's the secret to all of my
success I have calendar anorexia I want
as little in my calendar as possible I'm
meticulous about whatever the least
amount possible I can have in my
calendar without killing my entire
career that's what I want I want to set
up quick call to chat want to have
coffee next week let's get together to
discuss no no and no I could but I just
can't even if there are serious
opportunities even if the only took me
15 minutes even if it's something that
everyone else does I like to avoid it of
course I'm not perfect at this I do
succumb just like everybody else in the
modern world there are things that I
have to do and and those things have to
be scheduled there are requirements for
work and basic civility but even then
when I pull up my phone and I click on
today's date and I see little boxes of
time blocked out I get very nervous I
get anxious what is all this where did
my time go what about my day why did I
agree to all of this and then the most
fearful question how will I be able to
make my video you see my entire day is
my vlog time I can't schedule that and
if I do schedule that away it better be
because I'm getting paid or I really
want to do it because everything else
everything else is for suckers
see you've got managers and you got
makers there are two ways to run your
life
managers know that their day is divided
up into little itty-bitty pieces for
meetings calls and administrative tasks
makers on the other hand
makers need to have large blocks of
uninterrupted time to focus on what it
is they're making when people ask how
I'm able to get these videos done every
single day my calendar anorexia is the
answer
same goes without of able to manage a
healthy relationship with my wife and my
family and how I manage to exercise and
read time time is our most irreplaceable
asset we can't buy more of it we can't
get a second of it back we can only hope
to waste as little of it as possible
while we have it yet somehow we treat it
as the most renewable of all resources
so if the ask is if we can get together
and chat or pick my brain the answer is
no I'm sorry but I have this condition I
hope you understand
rule number two love the process success
for me is the process and I've realized
that every time in life where I've sort
of reached a been a benchmark that's
enabled me to pause when I pause and
misery yeah I hate it I hate it when I
sold my HBO series and I had two years
before it aired I was miserable doing it
exactly and I don't like that so I think
that like it the journey the process is
the reward for me so like right now
starting something new this is the most
successful time in my life and whatever
this yields like when that exit or
however it might manifest takes place
like sure that's great it's a cool story
but it doesn't equal happiness alright
like beam the most exciting part of
starting a tech company was you know
when it was my my Matt Hackett my
co-founder and I just the two of us
sitting in a room trying to figure out
that to me was like the pinnacle of
success you know when I was at MIT it
was like sitting in that lab every
single day across from these brilliant
minds that was the that was success for
me so the journey is what I strive for
and it's what excites me the most and
with three six eight it's like it's
really building to enable that journey
as much as possible I'm not focused at
all on a finish line there is no let's
raise 100 million dollars of venture
money and in existing a unicorn I could
give it like this I mean I feel like the
finish line is like every day for you
like every day it restarts and it's
there's no real yeah I mean the the
journey is the reward the work is the
reward rule number three be patient one
more question that came in
from smoking Joe how would I be as good
as you when my life isn't very
interesting and I can't afford decent
recording editing equipment I can't seem
to gain any growth after two years of
hard work hard work and patience are
really what's required to find success
in any field in life two years a very
small amount of time and you gotta be
prepared to commit everything if you
want to see do we have to get out had
such a good answer to me creativity is
the ability to be able to believe in the
way in which you see the world so much
that you actually create an art form out
of it and from what I understand like
video is an is an outlet it's a voice
poems aren't ugly music may be an outlet
it's it's a personal perception of the
world and the creation around that that
becomes interesting and I think that
like you've just got to keep at it
there's so many different ways of
finding execution and people that you
will find your work and platforms but if
you just keep and stay true to yourself
and the way in which you see things and
that's your watch your videos are about
that's interesting that you need that's
very beautiful
rule number four figure out your passion
one truth that I realize in life is that
there are really only two things you
should be doing if you consider yourself
a driven person a passionate person's
only two things you should be doing one
is figuring out what it is you want to
do like finding your passion finding
your dream what is it that you want to
do and the number two is realizing it
and now in retrospect in success I'm
able to tell you for a fact figuring it
out like that step one which seems so
easy a novel that is by far the hardest
thing to do and I think most people most
people don't interact with most people
in life aren't is lucky as I was to
stumble upon my passion so early in life
by the way that one step to step to
flesh that out a little bit more the
reason why I think the hard part is
figuring out what you want to do and the
easy part is just doing it is because if
it is something that truly drives you
like whatever that was that fire that
lit in front of me inside of me when I
first played
video on a computer there was no turning
that switch off I felt about it then at
age 18 or 19 living in a trailer like
with no money with no prospects in life
I was as passionate as excited in that
very moment as I am like an hour ago
shooting videos here in Dublin before
one of the thugs that works here at
Douglas Texas um it was like where are
you were supposed to be here an hour
going on like I'm making videos like I
was it has never faded for me it is my
patent is something that just excites me
to no end it's like when I see an old
rocker when I see Mick Jagger playing
music with the same kind of passion he
had when he was in his 20s and the
sixties playing music that's what it
felt like and to have that is it a
really elusive thing a really elusive
thing I look at the people that I know
that are happiest I look at my dad I
look at my friends and they all have
jobs and the jobs are a way for them to
sort of their job like most people have
jobs they make ends meet and it's a
necessity of life and they're happy in a
million ways but forever reason they
never had that whether you call it
fortuitous lucky or unlucky moment in
life where they found something that
made them absolutely possess something
that took over who they were rule number
five take action I just think I think
action action but yeah it's more action
which ultimately yields success but it's
like you know if it painting is what's
really exciting to you then pick up the
brush right and if it's if it's you know
singing then you know have the guitar
and sing more so I think you no matter
what your medium is I think it's it's
the act of doing that really that really
kind of paves that road yeah I know like
for me the most exciting part of making
a daily video when I started in 2015 was
like how much better I got so I learned
more in the first year of vlogging I
learned
15 years prior of making videos right
it's just when you're when you're
starting when you're acting that much
when there's that much action it just
you learned so much about not just the
medium but yourself and everything else
it's like what is it it's a vision
without vision without execution is
hallucination like that is yeah that is
the truth rule number six hustle
there have been a lot of questions
especially after we posted episode 1
about workflow like about how the edits
happen and how we work together so it
kinda goes like this when I did the vlog
I would shoot all day and all night post
the next morning that worked for 3 6 8
though I shoot all day I edit all night
and then the next morning instead of
posting I give that edit to dare and
that edit is like an incomplete edit to
story it so at that point in time the
narrative is together but all the other
stuff like all the other stuff like
color correction or sound design all
that takes so much time and then the
next day we post so it's like on a
Monday but if we shoot out in one day we
post that video on Wednesday instead of
on Tuesday and then we have to edit
tasks now this is all theory and we've
only done two edits so far and it's
already complicated disaster like it
seems so easy by giving us that extra
time but we haven't slept in four days
yeah
come to New York Casey see it can be fun
rule number seven be resourceful I went
to New York City with like a $800 no
place to live in a two-year-old kid and
I was like I'll reach for the stars like
I'm gonna do it and I moved to New York
City and it was tough and it was
struggle that it was unimaginable for me
prior to actually having lived it but my
first success the first real like taste
of the power of using the internet and
leveraging new technology was when I had
a movie go viral in 2003 and just like
paint a little bit of a picture for you
guys especially those of you under the
age of like 30 this is viral before
Twitter viral before Facebook viral
before any social media this is when the
word viral meant like what happens to an
STD in a frat house on a college campus
my viral was not used to describe movies
then like this was something that was
crazy like what it literally took was
you'd have to watch this video that I
posted on a splash page a website
because YouTube wasn't born for three
more years get it like cut the URL copy
start
email type out all the addresses of
people that you want to send it to put
it in the message box with a funny thing
that says lol haha watch this click send
and then just hope everybody does that
like the idea of a movie going viral was
such a foreign thing but here it was I
made this little movie and all sudden it
was seen 5 million times and I start
doing the math in my head and I'm like
wow if I had a feature film that was
seen that many times it would have to be
on the level of like a gigantic
Hollywood movie and this movie cost me
40 bucks like for no money I just made a
little movie that was fun and pretty
such a pretty stupid movie it's a really
stupid movie but it reached this massive
audience and that's when it really
occurred to me at that moment like my
passion that drive was so much more
driven to using this medium as a way to
communicate ideas and perspectives than
it was to the formality the mechanical
part of making movies and that's why I
say and I say it at nauseam and I'll say
it my whole life my whole career the
gear doesn't matter it really doesn't
matter what tools you're using to share
your ideas or share your perspectives
it's just getting them out there and if
you can share in a way that connects
with people you will break through rule
number eight find happiness what is
being satisfied like we're all gonna be
dead yeah there I mean there's no come
on
like no if is this like fleeting stupid
thing like some people get more time
than others but like it's not there is
no like you know no level of success is
gonna take you anywhere that the the
richest person in the end gets the same
exact thing is the poorest person so he
gives us what makes you really happy and
I tried relaxing I've tried sitting on
the beach I've tried like chilling out
I've tried singing in fancy hotels in
ordering room service that just makes me
bored and miserable yeah I hate vacation
I hate relaxation yeah work is the only
thing that really really keeps me
motivated and keeps me happy in the
morning I'm a better like father I'm a
better of a husband right point when I'm
working than when I'm not well number
nine find your motivation city
I had nothing else okay dirt poor kid no
education and I met all these rich kids
and I realize that I was like Todd they
have trust funds they have money than
all these resources all these worries
that I have they don't get to sleep over
something about me tomorrow
they don't have it I'm so jealous of
these people and any of them I didn't
watch grow up and we grew up together
that I watch them grow up in to really
struggle to find a purpose in life
because they didn't have to they didn't
need to find a purpose we go out there
and fight to find a job I didn't need
you out there and just like take no
prisoners and work for the night because
that your survival was on the line you
could always like and I'm just in here
in debt I've got a trust fund I'll be
there in the morning I pass them and I
think the job that I wasn't before rich
I'm very happy and I just struggled so
much for my career does that's my source
of motivation I know what happens if I
stop easy and it sucks and it's terrible
I never want to go back there so I'll
always be fighting so if you have sense
of that I don't know I don't know that's
all I've ever known and rule number ten
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is don't fail to try I needed a
hard reset I needed a break see when
you're sitting so close to something
when you're standing in the forest and
the trees are blinding you like
only focus is your next upload it makes
it hard to see the big picture hard to
see the totality of where you are where
do you want to be and the best path to
get you there and all that was furthered
by the fact that my videos in this
channel and making content of my own has
not been my priority for a very very
long time
officially I ended the vlog in fall of
2016 it's not clickbait
I really am ending the vlog and I spent
that the following year plus trying to
build something new and ultimately I
failed
[Music]
failure sucks but the pain that is
failure does not exceed the pain that is
not trying at all see see I regret my
failures but I would regret more a
failure to try
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from KC on how to seek collaborations
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions it's time to
move from just watching under the video
to actually taking action in your life
or in your business so answer these
three questions number one what is your
motivation to keep going number two what
do you need to make this week and number
three how can you plan more action
taking into your regular calendar
you've spoken about the ice cube and
you've spoken about how the ice cube is
like an idea and when you pass it around
to too many people it melts and you've
explained that collaborating is almost
like that so in this new endeavor of
collaboration how do you sort of balance
that collaboration versus doing things
you're sure I mean I think creativity by
committee
is is different from the idea of
collaborating you know I think that like
I think that if you think of the Beatles
is a number of different musicians
coming together and together
collaborating to create amazing music
it's very different from you know
institutionalizing music where there are
filters and approvals and and that kind
of systematic creative thinking and
certainly what the way that I know that
I collaborate best is I work with people
who had their own creative vision and I
step into their world and we make
something together and then they step
into my world and we make something
together so I think that by definition
is sort of siloing your own sort of
defining unique characteristics around
creativity instead of marginalizing it
by trying to make it something that is
more you know Universal raise your
standard Apple at the core is core
values
is that we believe that people have
passion and change the way people not
one drop of myself work depends on your
it's suppose to mean
if you want to learn from another
YouTube filmmaker who also recently
collaborated with Casey my stat I highly
recommend my top 10 on Peter McKinnon
the link is right next to me I'll see
you there you're gonna get better once
you go through the you know how do you
take good photos it takes thousands of
bad